what if trump and biden just don't both
drop out at the last minute and then
kanye wins
i think it's funny i think i think kanye
tweeted the other day he's like no man
should have that kind of power i don't
care it's like bro dude you thought you
were yeah i'm sorry did he really think
he was gonna win oh actually maybe maybe
maybe
maybe this was actually a fake tweet
that i saw and should have fact checked
did i just spread fake news
i think maybe i did but i caught it hey
you know what i called it i bet he did
say it because he has a song called
power and it says no one man should have
all that power
oh so he's correct kanye i think that's
from a song
did you guys did you guys did you guys
know that facebook tracks
violence incitement they do yeah what do
you mean
facebook has a meter where they're like
like
tracking the words people use determine
how angry and violent they're becoming
yeah what's up seriously check it out
from buzzfeed news facebook has an
internal metric for violence and
incitement trends
right now it's rising thank you buzzfeed
for making me feel more comfortable
the metric which assesses the potential
for danger based on keywords rose to 580
from 400 this week a 45
increase what does that mean that
doesn't mean anything to me does that
mean people
are being violent like they want to be
violent they're going to be violent what
is it are they reading our minds what's
going on
when they can know when we're no but
like what's what's a 579 mean do they do
they tell us they say
as votes are being tallied blah blah
blah in opposed to a group on facebook's
internal messaging board one employee
alerted their colleagues to a nearly 45
percent increase in the metric
which assesses the potential for danger
based on hashtags and search terms
over the last five days the post which
was seen by buzzfeed news notes that
trends were previously rising slowly
but that recently some conspiracy theory
and general unhappiness post hashtags
were gaining popularity
the probable violence and incitement
metric for explore
has been slowly rising over the past
over the last few days
the post's author wrote referring to
facebook's explore search tool
the risky hashtag seem conspiracy
theory-esque
the internal metric which has not been
which has not previously been reported
has been around a score of 400 on
october 31
and then it started rising to 580 as of
thursday morning
yeah yeah they say they ban violence
incitement the rapid uptick in violence
and incitement number indicates the
company's own internal metrics have
found facebook posts are contributing
to an unstable situation around the
counting of ballots in the us
presidential election
as donald trump and his supporters
attempt to inject unfounded doubts into
the process i love how buzzfeed just
has to put that in there extra words man
pretty sure people have videos of things
that are freaking them out
i believe all of these things should be
investigated because could you imagine
if biden wins and none of these things
are investigated and then we get four
years of
joe biden cheated like i'm not
interested i think if the democrats are
very confident they're going to win then
then look into these things and debunk
them if you think they're not true
if if if buzzfeed says once say they're
unfounded okay buzzfeed
write an article about it and tell me
why it's unfounded prove it
otherwise don't waste my time
they say these hashtags which are
gaining popularity point to the overall
theme
the employee wrote of democrats stealing
the election
not trusting the results and supporting
trump i wouldn't panic because most
these hashtags aren't very prevalent
but it does seem to be building a
building trend that ideally we stop
before it gains momentum
the employee said in their post while
these hashtags aren't as explicitly
risky as rigged election and voter fraud
they do promote similar ideas given we
have approval to block those hashtags it
would be great if we could come up with
a standard
for these borderline hashtags they're
saying
what the h are they if you tweet
something like democrats are stealing
the election
or if you post that on facebook they
will get rid of you because you're
inciting violence
because you're contributing to this
trend of ideas that's interesting they
don't want you to think or share
information
goodbye project veritas oh yeah veritas
is going to get nuked
i mean look mark ruffalo he tweeted
earlier there is not a single shred of
evidence to anything trump is claiming
talking about the voter fraud yeah it's
all listen it's all lies
and it's not going to go anywhere with
the courts he has lost
all but one lawsuit because he has no
credible
claims and mark ruffalo would know he's
who i go to he is the authority but i
mean really think about this
like with all these college students in
universities that have like
they need safe spaces they have crazy
ptsd because of 2016.
the media creates this narrative the
media puts it out and says
this is this this is that hillary's
gonna bomb biden's gonna bomb
they say that this isn't real there's no
fraud nothing here going on
but then the truth comes out they can't
deal with reality
they have ptsd it's like they did this
to them
so like i'm speaking to these kids right
now it's like the reason why you have
such terrible ptsd
is because the media people like mark
ruffalo lie to you
they cause you to believe that this is
actually not happening
and then the truth comes out and your
whole you're completely disillusioned
your whole world is a lie it's not
donald trump's fault it's the media that
lies to you
but you know what you know what really
was surprising to me i was surprised to
find that mark ruffalo's intelligence is
closer to that of the hulk than to
doctor
i'm inclined to agree i really agree
yeah yeah
you know that's his secret he's always
wrong he's always
they don't realize how hypocritical
these people are
it's like these people are
multi-millionaires i know they're
standing with socialism
dude i bet you a bunch of them secretly
voted for trump because they're super
rich
because
someone tweeted like this mike this uh
this election may get dragged out until
january whatever
and then oh we just lost internet and
then glenn greenwald said well we're
recording so i'll just keep going
uh glenn uh they they uh
someone tweeted that it's gonna get
dried out till january and glenn
greenwald tweeted
that's uh great because it gives the
lincoln project more time to take to to
take money from the
you know something like that true i love
it it gives resistance democrats more
time to transfer their bank account
funds over to the lincoln project
exactly something like that that's a
good that's an excellent point i
appreciate you in saying that
i don't know what's going on with the
internet but uh you know the good news
is that the verizon people finally came
yeah maybe they'll get it before we have
real internet hopefully before the
exactly what you know look when i see
the story about facebook
and the and the violence rising stuff
they start banning people i think that
contributes to
people getting angrier and angrier and
i've had people i've seen comments on
videos and stuff where they say things
like what do i do i'm starting to feel
very powerless
yeah like your vote doesn't matter
you're being ignored the media is lying
to you what do you do
i'm worried people are gonna are gonna
start going nuts and that's what we
don't want to happen
but uh i mean what are what are people
going to do
yeah on the right absolutely right and
the left is already snapped a long time
ago these people have lost the plot yeah
so do you guys think that the right has
a leg to stand on if they were to melt
down and go crazy and cause trouble
because i was i remember this cnn
reporter was talking about these
gun-toting people in arizona
saying you know count the vote or stop
the vote or whatever she's like they're
carrying long
guns she sounded like she was reporting
from a war zone like nothing has
happened with those guns nothing's going
to happen with those guns those people
are perfectly fined perfectly in their
rights to pray
so what's the deal why should right
wingers not riot
like what's what's stopping them rioting
is bad
of course no no i hear you you know what
i'm saying though right
i think if it is true if the things that
appear to be sketchy truly are
yeah and of course people have a right
to demand some kind of investigation
for this to be seriously looked into and
remedied uh that's pretty much all i can
say at this point i'm not sure it feels
like we lost the war with china
yeah it feels like we lost a great meme
war
frankly i'm just thinking about the
first meme
i think i think capitalism has been
exploited to a great degree
where you get people like the lincoln
project that's true i think i think the
hilarious thing
is uh like this idea of a grifter yeah
the left is always like you're a grifter
they're a grifter they're griffin
i certainly think they're right-wing
grifters for sure but like the lincoln
project is the most well-funded drifting
operation
ever oh my goodness see seeing people
like you know jennifer rubin of the
washington post she's a conservative
because she cheers for like far left
democrats like
dude you know come on well yeah i cheer
for far less democrats
i cheer for joe biden we discussed this
we're grifters now we're all
joking we are christopher's whole thing
we're grifting hard and cast irl
on the biden train yeah correct sir we
are chugging
choo choo in tunes yeah aoc tunes the
best tunes biden matters i don't know
what's going on with ops over here yeah
the internet's on the fritz because
we're talking about
naughty things yeah we're talking about
bad things are we are we getting hashtag
throttled right now maybe
what's happening i don't think so the
comment section is going crazy
are they saying it's suppression
yeah that's what it is so uh yeah man i
don't want to be in the city i think
we're back
and uh i mean it's been it's been
cutting in and out it just cut out again
there's nothing we can do about it
we're chilling i don't want to be in any
cities for the time being
yeah i'm good yeah so so i still do live
actually i was just up there and uh
we're you know we're still we're still
pretty much on the east coast i just
don't want to be
within walking distance you know or or i
guess
or uber distance we'll call that we'll
call it uber distance yeah
so still this i mean i'm not i'm not
going to give any locations but
i i'm moving out of cali i left you are
i can give locations i know where he's
moving
if trump loses this thing like like i
mean dealing with antifa black lives
matter these these people want
revolution they want to destroy the
system and
if you're in like a heavy huge blue
state blue city
like if the police get defunded
no one's no one's gonna help you and
you're being convinced as a leftist that
guns are bad you're being convinced as a
leftist that
even the thought of a gun is evil do you
think something like changes who's going
to come in who's
who i think i think change will only
come when this starts knocking on your
door
i think i think that's case i don't want
to buy any guns or anything like that
yeah and then the riots got too close
and i was like they're defunding the
police i had someone trying to break
into my house and so i was like time to
go buy some guns
yeah yeah i mean that's a reasonable uh
that's a reasonable approach to take
someone tries to break in your house
also
i mean i think people should just have
guns generally speaking to defend
themselves
i did a cartoon about this uh when the
the riots broke out about guns
oh that's yeah about the mobs and how um
i mean i
was hoping thinking that for the time
being the gun control conversation would
pretty much be dead because
across the country and they aren't
discussing it as much recently
but uh of course it'll come back
people's memories spans unfortunately
joe biden's joe biden's gun plan is like
the most radical thing we've ever seen
i know why do you think that is because
they want to be able to get away with
this kind of rioting
they want to be able to intimidate
people they want to be able to go to the
suburbs they do
it's it's kind of inconvenient when
people are able to protect themselves
and their families it makes you a little
less powerful when you're trying to
intimidate them with your numbers
you know you know the big issue is that
the obama administration
they they and and and the republicans
and the democrats back in the 90s
they didn't just erode uh the market
the markets and the economy and jobs
overnight it was
very very slow to the point where you
know what let me tell you a story
did you know the story about how ebay
changed the color of its website no
ebay used to be yellow and then they
decided one day we're gonna make ebay
white
and they changed it and everyone flipped
out and they were like no
it's bad change it back we hate it so
they started they changed it back like
okay whoa
then every day they slowly did one
increment towards white
and then a year later the website was
white and no one noticed oh wow no one
had noticed a change
it's kind of cool that's what the frog
in the boiling water exactly boiling
frogs
so that's what i think we're going to
see i don't think joe biden's going to
do anything dramatically could you
imagine if right when he gets in office
he goes like we're signing the deal to
destroy the suburbs and then he likes
tearing down suburbs and like like trump
part of the green new deal get rid of
something
we got to change the buildings yeah
first climate agreement here's the thing
um this this insane monolithic
bureaucratic super state that's spying
on everybody
and waging these completely
unsustainable wars in the middle east
uh and taxing people at unbelievably
high rates was not built overnight
this is something that they had to work
their way to one new policy at a time
right yeah so they're they're so you
know i just think it's funny joe biden
he wants to raise the corporate tax rate
to what like 39
right the obama administration and biden
were in favor of the trans-pacific
partnership
okay they're also in favor of a 15
minimum wage
put those things together what do you
get it's going to work okay here's what
happens
you say free trade between the u.s and
china
if you work in this country if you the
company's got to pay you 15 bucks an
hour
and we're going to tax that company 40
yeah so the company says
so what you're telling me is if i go in
china where i can pay a quarter an hour
to foxconn you know laborers who live in
cubicles i don't got to pay them health
care
i don't got to pay 15 bucks and i got to
pay corporate tax rate but i got to keep
all the profits
done yeah free trade i can ship the
products back in with no tariffs no
costs
done because biden all vital definitely
that's what they were
doing yeah and that's one of the reasons
i think trump got elected because they
were eroding the manufacturing base
like purposefully allowing it to be
destroyed yeah yeah
well that's coming back baby it's coming
back i think it's gonna be if biden wins
we don't actually know
but here's the thing like if you if you
have someone as a low information voter
and you splash hot coffee in their face
and then they go ah my face hurts why
does my face hurt and you say
it's because trump and they go trump's
bad he made my face hurt and you're like
that's right here take another you
splash them in the face again no
trump make it stop and then biden
splashes them in the face with coffee
and you're like don't blame me i voted
for trump it's like you know a better
way to put it is like
they're alone in an elevator with joe
biden and he lets one rip and then he
looks at him and goes
it was you hey there fat there's uh
trump
he did it he came in elevator and fired
and left he just didn't notice
he never knew no but they they they
elevator shaft they
their policies have had led to an
erosion and what did obama say
what kind of magic wand do you have to
bring back manufacturing
and then donald trump did it sure did
brought back manufacturing their
policies
cause destruction they wreak havoc they
destroy families they destroy businesses
you have like paramilitary organizations
like antifa and black lives matter
they create these problems and then they
present themselves as the saviors
to eradicate those problems this is why
you have joe biden
telling the country that he's gonna heal
the nation right do you honestly believe
is that such a creepy thing to see
joe biden says he'll heal the nation was
restored the no the was restore the soul
of the nation one of his acts
i saw that on a yard sign and i wasn't
sure if that was actually some weird
thing that somebody said
yeah which is just another way of saying
make america great again like
a more like creepy spiritual way
yeah build back better well here's the
thing about joe biden he might sound
nice and he might say things like you
know rebuild the soul of america and fix
his problems and heal
its wounds he accuses trump supporters
of being
nazis yeah he introduced his whole
campaign with the concept of the
the charlottesville it was a lie the
charlottesville hoax very fine people
verifying people.org dispels it
and they talk up it's just he's the
worst he's just
nice looking and he seems old and feeble
yeah and also speaking of
nazis the idea of a nation like having a
soul or the
the nation being an ethical entity is
literally fascism factually
yeah you know i do want to mention
something really funny i watched this
video from the pennsylvania i think
uh secretary of state or aj or whatever
she's like
so one of the journalists asked her why
is it that there are more mail and belts
being reported than melon balls
requested and she went oh
that's just you know like we got
computers and people will label things
and like
it was just a mistake so ignore that oh
it reminds me you guys ever watch
venture brothers yes when like that i
can't remember
it's been so long where the guy's in the
back of the car and he's like ignore me
so what happens is you've got mail-in
ballots coming into pennsylvania
at a higher rate than were requested so
there's like a chart showing like 49 000
belts
uh requested 150 000 you know returned
so it doesn't make sense yeah and then
she goes oh just you know it was a
reporting error like
the numbers are being fixed don't worry
about that so i think we should worry
about that
you know what worried me about
pennsylvania was the uh agent saying
he won biden would have won when they
tallied all the votes
i was like yeah that's an interesting
prediction to make it so really weird
gentleman who likes joe biden and who
hates donald trump that is an
interesting prediction to make yeah i
mean like think about this they
think last time they stopped they
stopped counting trump
votes yeah right in some states like at
11 30
p.m they say they're gonna take a break
they're gonna wait
uh-huh and then overnight all these
magical
biden votes that came out of nowhere but
really think about it really think about
it
why are they saying that they're gonna
stop counting but then overnight
obviously someone was counting this is
what the georgia republicans pointed out
that they said that they had to they
were stopping for the night for
administrative reasons
and then immediately started counting
again and when no one was watching yeah
there was about i think it was like
almost ten to twenty thousand magical
votes
ballots that were all biden but it's
happened in a bunch of places i will say
in in uh michigan people kept keep
sharing this meme why i shouldn't call
it meme but
it's photos of 120 thousands only for
biden
and the official announcement from the
new york times was a failure
in i think it was edison research it was
it was a reporting error by the
company tracking the ballots and that it
was just they fixed it
and then i'm seeing all these people say
like oh no this is crazy and i'm seeing
like conservatives say we gotta point
this out
and i'm like guys they said the same
thing about arizona in trump's favor
i'll tell you one of the problems i had
with trump's press conference he's like
you know you look at these states where
we're winning
and then just overnight our lead starts
being whittled away whittled away
you know and the opposite is happening
in arizona
where joe biden is winning and joe
biden's lead is slowly being whittled
away
so it's like don't make that argument if
you want to make an argument that the
democrats conspired and they're doing
all this crazy stuff then like
then they're doing it and they're really
smart they made it so it was a razor
thin win
they made it so that it's also happening
to to joe in a state they didn't need
i think look i think there's dirty games
play but i don't think it's a
uh i don't think it's what people think
it is they think there's like a meeting
that happens where obama
walks in and comes out of the shadows
like it's like a parking garage and like
he's wearing a trench coat
and he's like joe here's the file and he
like kicks a
manila folder and joe and then joe opens
and sees the plan now what really
happens is
you've got a bunch of crazy people who
don't need to be communicated with to do
things that are dirty
like there's there's a video of a guy
and you can see him he's reading a
ballot and he starts marking something
and no one knows what it is we don't
know what he was marking or why
but a lot of people on the right are
saying that's a guy like
you can't do that he's putting he's like
and the camera pans away real quick
it's like okay it's not that there's a
grand conspiracy it's that
you need poll watchers because you might
get one person being like
trump crumple throw it away right that's
the problem that's why trump was right
to sue to make sure that people could be
monitoring what was going on and then
democrats
they challenged it yeah that was what's
causing me to question is like oh yeah
why why are you challenging something
that will only vindicate you well aren't
they the ones who are constantly crying
about the democracy
aren't they the ones who are constantly
crying about counting every single vote
here they are not doing it fighting
trump when he's trying to do it
i hate it i really don't like it it's
making me really mad it seems like the
whole thing is just a bunch of cheating
and i'm not a conspiracy theorist but i
don't think that at every level
at every level democrat operatives are
acting well i'll tell you what
if the republicans knew for a year
what the democrats were talking about
doing or what they were planning or
whatever and they didn't do anything
about it then why should i be
sympathetic and that's fair
i think i think trump should fight every
legal fight he can i think he should
uh not just you know give up easily
i think he should say here's what we
think is happening here's what we're
gonna do we're gonna file the suits and
you know we'll see if we win
and right now it's like it's close trump
could win
yeah so uh but it you know if it comes
out
if it comes out that they do uncover
fraud or something
good great let's get it all in the open
the doj said that they're going to
investigate any actionable intelligence
that they can
but you know it depends on what they get
a lot of people don't understand that
these videos that are circulating are
not necessarily actionable intelligence
they can look into and be like what do
we do if there's a claim that a poll
worker took a stack of bouts and
shuffled them together
what do they do you can pick up that
stack and you're not going to know which
ballot came from where that's sneaky
nothing you can do about it i don't like
that
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you